[play music]
MAX CIOCIOLA: My name is Max Ciociola.
Is the CEO and founder of musiXmatch
My daily work is all about music and lyrics.
Listen to the product team's recommendations to create the ultimate experience
This app is called musiXmatch
Because we aim to match your music to the lyrics
We will show you the lyrics when you play the music.
So far, we’ve been amazed at the results of our partnership with Google Play.
Our app downloads are as high as 27 million, of which more than 16 million are from the Android platform.
That is Google Play
Up to 10 million active users per month
Faster than any other platform
The floating lyrics experience is perfectly integrated into
Media [inaudible] logo on Android devices
This means you don’t even have to open the app
Play tracks whenever and where music service
You will receive a notification immediately
If you touch and open the notification
Will see it immediately
a lyric overlay that exactly matches the music and is synchronized
This means more and more users will use our app.
The usage time will be longer and longer, and the interaction will be more and more
This is only possible with the Android platform.
So far we have found
Significant increase in engagement
Not only has the number of active users more than doubled
Their average time spent in the app has more than doubled
SEBASTIANO GOTTARDO: no doubt
Android is a true open system
This platform is developing rapidly and well received.
You are free to create a variety of applications and features
Create endless possibilities
For example, on musiXmatch we created a floating lyrics experience
This is not possible in any other mobile device operating system.
MAX CIOCIOLA: Compared to any other platform
The reason why the Android platform is very important to us is
We can respond to each user’s review
Communicate directly with them
This is a big advantage of the Android platform.
Listen to the voice of the user and find a way for them
Create a thoughtful experience
Chromecast brings a big screen experience you can with friends
Sitting around in my living room, watching the lyrics and singing together
These experiences have greatly improved the level of interaction
In addition to smartphones and tablets
Your watch can also display lyrics directly
SEBASTIANO GOTTARDO: Promising for Android TV development
Because this platform is not only very useful
And we can create a variety of different experiences.
This is an exciting opportunity for our application.
MAX CIOCIOLA: Our goal is to reach 100 million users
The specific method is
Take advantage of the technological innovation opportunities available to develop applications on the Android platform
And we can’t get this opportunity on other platforms.
[play music]